che venivo da tre
troppa
l'osteria vicino barbera e bar doney
novità
poi sono tornato a casa
c'è ora c'è un bel mi sono sentito colpo
al cuore tanto
palma che si vede ma non c'è già più
mamma che si vede manas
non c'è già più
alla reggenza c'era un vestito sera che
ha portato poi al piano
non ci andava lì con l'iss console ai
patti super hi tech ma il toscano
non c'è che posto è ci dicono che sia
progresso parte
adesso mamma che si vede ma non c'è già
più ma marche si vedeva lassù non si
vede più
ma no che si vedeva da lassù non c'è già
più mamma che si vede la la massima
non si vede più
mamma che si vedeva da lassù non c'è già
più
grazie grazie a tutti grazie ronga beat
music
cambiamo ok musica con oggetti domestici
si può fare direi pò crisi
questa è la dimostrazione che qualunque
oggetto che noi abbiamo a casa può
diventare strumento musicale e si può
utilizzare per fare musica
la canzone che avete sentito poco fa è
una nostra composizione si intitola
tanti anni fa e provate a immaginare chi
possa averla composta il maestro
giovanni mazzara quarta te una band che
va bene un gruppo un gruppo ecologico
che raccoglie oggetti di uso comune
lasciate in disuso che vengono raccolti
da discariche cantine nei raggi soffitte
dove sono stati dimenticati e dove non
hanno più non scopo di raccogliamo di ri
modellismo e adattiamo al nostro scopo
che a creare lo strumento musicale
quindi diventano oggetti musicali
diventano anzi dei veri e propri
attrezzi musicali le sonorità del dei
nostri strumenti sono differenti e
questo è tutto il fatto che facciamo una
raccolta differenziata di materiali
quindi vetro plastica alluminio carta e
cartoni
insomma un po tutti i materiali vengono
scelti per creare uno strumento che
abbiano una peculiarità che sia il suono
vero e proprio dell'oggetto che noi
abbiamo riciclato e riconvertito quindi
cerchiamo di riprodurre i suoni degli
strumenti veri e propri
la nostra idea fondamentale
fondamentalmente è quella di fare
strumenti musicali che io non sono curo
quindi cerchiamo per noi naturali di non
utilizzare effetti quindi quello che
avete sentito adesso è proprio il suono
dei nostri strumenti non ci sono
distorsioni non ci sono e chi non ci
sono di lei insomma siamo musicisti ci
piace suonare a un plug e quindi suono
che voi avete sentito adesso è il vero
proprio suono da riciclo
quindi andiamo a vedere un po questi
strumenti presentiamoli allora nella
nostra analisi sugli strumenti dei
manzella partiamo dal bie don basso che
è lo strumento alla vostra sinistra che
suona joe ganga è costituito da un
bidone dell'olio una ri loga per le
tende e una corda per stendere i panni
adesso che ci mostrerà perché il bidone
basso è meglio di un contrabbasso
dell'accordo del contrappasso costava
troppo
altra un applauso per il coraggio
continuando il nostro viaggio negli
strumenti del manzella quartet
incontriamo la taglia che suona alex che
è letteralmente una teglia per le
lasagne una teglia da forno infatti a
casa sua non si mangia più non si
mangiano più lasagne su cui è stato
montato il manico di una chitarra
classica
adesso lui ci fa la sentiva non
assatanati simo
beh è una chitarra vera e propria questa
notte in via terzo strumento che vi
mostriamo è la wolf che si suona davide
come vedete è riciclata anche la sua
immagine è stata appiccicata alla
faccina praticamente questo qua è un
oggetto che è caduto in disuso perché
ormai le lavatrici vengono usate
comunemente no quindi l'asse per lavare
i panni non sapevamo più come
utilizzarlo e davide s'è ritrovato nella
scomoda posizione di dover trovare una
maniera creativa per suonare questo
questo oggetto prego davide
una grattugia diciamo
allora l'ultimo strumento che vi
mostriamo di quelli che avete già visto
suonare l'eco batteria che è questo
assortimento di questo ammasso di gli
oggetti che composto da bidoni secchi
pentole coperchi qualsiasi cosa si possa
per potere
l'effetto è proprio quello della
batteria cliente rilievo
andando oltre con gli strumenti che non
avete ancora visto abbiamo il batti fono
che è una sorta di xilofono costruito
con un oggetto che abbiamo tutti in casa
ma senza neanche saperlo cioè i
battiscopa prendendo i battiscopa e
tagliandoli di una lunghezza adatta a
generare diciamo una sorta di nota
abbastanza intonata non è non è così
facile è stato costruito bhatti sono che
ci dimostra sempre davide ok
diplomati in conservatorio suonato
cinque anni al conservatorio non gli
hanno mai aperto andata male prossimo
strumento è il tappo anello che vedete
in foto e che ha in mano davide è uno
strumento difficilissimo da costruire
come potete immaginare perché i cembali
che vedete benissimo nella foto sono
fatti con dei tappi a capsula quelli che
vengono usati per le birre
quindi voi potete immaginare quante sere
ci siamo dovuti trovare bere birra
insomma poi è una cosa abbastanza
difficile non ridete perché è complicato
quindi dopo tutta questa fatica abbiamo
costruito il tappo lello che ci illustra
ok
e concludiamo un applauso per valido
concludiamo con la punta di diamante
dell'intera strumentazione del manzella
quartet che el innaffiato sono ragazzi
l'innaffiatoio è sostanzialmente un
sassofono costruito con con un
innaffiatoio prego è in fase di
miglioramento ma era troppo bello per
farvelo vedere
ovviamente noi suoniamo come avete visto
o siamo suonati dipende dai punti di
vista e facciamo concerti concerti sia
nei locali sia fuori soprattutto live
perché pensiamo che il pubblico sia il
giudice migliore e noi abbiamo iniziato
con la strada abbiamo fatto i primi
busker festival e li abbiamo imparato in
una grande verità alcuni amici miei
svizzeri non parlavano bene italiano
della svizzera tedesca
quando arrivai a questo busker festival
mi dissero 40 strada è bello su ogni
bene stallo suo animale
quindi è il miglior metodo per capire di
essere suoni bene nel suo animale poi
ovviamente facciamo dei laboratori per i
ragazzi perché insegniamo loro a sapere
punto dove di rella le varie differenze
dei suoni ea costruire questi questi
strumenti e per ultimo ultimamente siamo
ci hanno chiamato parecchie volte a fare
dei team building per riuscire a dare
una nota ludica alla costruzione di
squadre
nell'ambito delle aziende quindi
nell'ambito dell'azienda dove tutti i
manager sono ricche insomma si stufano
un po sentire tutte le varie cose
diamo quella nota e ludicità e li
facciamo cantare e suonare insieme a noi
bene proposito quindi di suonare cantare
insieme a noi avete trovato sulle vostre
sedie un oggettino uno strumento
musicale riciclato praticamente sono gli
strumenti che utilizziamo noi ora
cominceremo a suonare e voi sarete con
noi quindi seguite il tempo del maestro
e chi non ha lo strumento musicale po
schioccare le dita senza problemi due
mani per volta non di più
bene perfetto chi non sa strumento
schiocchi le dita
questa è la nostra composizione si
intitola il panino assassino dedicata a
tutti gli automobilisti che ogni giorno
devono affrontare un anti loro viaggi
questo ha chiari mou nemico del nostro
stomaco salgo le scale si apre la porta
a tutto al bancone una coda è finita ma
chi se ne importa
pardi panini nella vetrina segno caprese
camogli un'attiva lipari cugina finisce
1 1
senza fiatare marino leggero con tanta
verdura ma non esagerano dolce fanciulla
come
ed è passare alla cassa perché qui
nessuno si fida un grande sorriso non
piano un dolcetto con l'aggiunta di 80
centesimi a un menù perfetto
prendo panino e una coca
mi guardo in giro e una bella signora un
bambino che gioca
come d'uscita su quel cartello cinque
chilometri in mezzo alla parte di questo
e di quello semplice arietta torno a
guidare sono casi vicino al casello e
comincio a star male sono in ritardo
siamo a cantù porca paletta il panino
non va nessuno
brescia
questi panini della strada sono le brevi
lo stress di una vita spietata
dare
ora facciamo un'altra canzone nostra che
s'intitola l'inno del riciclo
amico ovunque vai qualche cosa troverai
per esempio un legno poi per qualche
sono non buttare via ma niente
alternativamente a cosenza scrivania
qualche melodia suonare un gioco che
costa poco con il riciclo risparmierà i
letti di fiumi nella campana che cosa
strana
suona anche lei come jingle nella testa
e faremo una grande festa si spostano
una tu porti pure tu
se tu vuoi un comico segue sono terricci
ogni cosa che è finita la portiamo a
nuova vita
suonare un gioco che costa poco comuni e
triciclo risparmi rai net ieri nella
campana che cosa strana zona anche lei
omb single nanà test e faremo una grande
festa si spostano laggiù poi miuti pure
tu
grazie